I'm very close to the Trump family I
know them well and I spoke to Baron
after the incident and I look forward to
once I am free being with Donald Trump
in person and reminding him that he's a
bulletproof badass so why is he all of a
sudden close to the Trump
Administration I know this might be
funny but we are really actually doing
this we are teaching Salah to the
descendants of the Roman soldiers
imagine the sahaba fighting Roman
soldiers and one of them accepts Islam
and they teach him how to pray Sal and
he goes back to Rome and teaches his
family how to pray Salah and his kids
and his grandkids will become Muslim and
to this day they are Muslims how many
Salas were prayed since the day he
accepted Islam from just 10 you can
teach one to three people to learn how
to pray Salah I traveled with a team all
the way to Italy to deliver prayer mats
so the rever that are taking the shahada
and the Muslims who do know how to pray
Salah will learn from these prayer mats
we have opened Salah hubs where reverts
and Muslims who don't how to pray Salah
can go and learn how to pray Salah Allah
has allowed you to watch this video in
the month of Ramadan and giving you a
choice to teach someone how to pray
Salah or lose out donate just £100 now
and help teach 10 to 30 people how to
pray Salah now every single time they
pray is all for you remember the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him said that
charity will never decrease your wealth
click on the button and donate now
[Music]
brothers and sisters and dear friends
why is Andrew Tate close to the Trump
family why is Andrew Tate the moment his
van is lifted due to pressures from the
Trump Administration he heads straight
to the US is he a Israeli asset an
indirect asset the question everyone's
asking why are the T ROMs in the US so
his article controversial influence
adate and his brother Tristan have
landed in the US after leaving romia
where they were facing charges including
human trafficking which they deny now
agut has been a figure that has been
there's been a big question mark on him
since he's accepted Islam U his
loyalties where his loyalties lies I'll
be honest with you and U I mean it's
good to be close with your brother
there's nothing wrong with being very
close to your brother except is your
blood but we believe that of course
blood is thicker than water but we
believe faith in Islam is thicker than
blood and that is where what's loyalties
should be lying but anyways so we're
going to work some videos inah and see
what we can make out because obviously
there were some accusations made towards
it but we're going to see what is the
real reasons behind all this is Israel
playing a big role because as we know
with theepan islands and how they tried
to have leverage and try to frame people
this could be a clear clear tactic of
Israel try to leverage Andrew Tate let's
watch influencer Andrew Tate has been
detained The Matrix has attacked me we
were arrested on a garbage case with no
evidence in it there's no evidence of
crimes they printed an indictment with
thousands of pieces of paper which
doesn't mean anything they falsified
evidence the whole thing is garbage what
have they found on us you don't see any
girls with bruises where's the victims
of all this the evidence was gathered
illegally illegal wir Taps false
translations fake witnesses that don't
even exist there was never any evidence
to put me in jail okay if there is no
evidence to put you in jail which I can
believe I can say you know what there
were no evidences no problem who's
orchestrating all of this who's
orchestrating you getting arrested false
charges who's put this pressure because
they're going to use you later they know
how much influence you have that can be
a possibility let's carry on watching
any EV there was never any evidence to
raid my house five times there was never
any evidence to keep me travel banned
for 3 years there was never any evidence
to stop me seeing my children there was
never any evidence to stop me seeing my
mother when she had a heart attack there
was never any evidence to steal all of
my cars and all of my money and all of
my wealth there was never any evidence
to the media which were very complicit
when somebody wants to intimidate you
like the mafia gang members or the
government for that matter they show you
their true capabilities and power and
then they back off just so they can let
you know what they are capable of doing
that's the reason why when Muhammad
hijab was threatened yes blackmailed
that they be he'll be framed just to
show their capabilities let's carry on
to try their very best to slander me
this is a set up it is done on purpose
and it is designed to come up with the
most heinous possible crimes to slander
our name this is
disgusting my brother and I have always
been innocent
we were attacked because of our
Monumental Fame and the work we were
doing at the time to break the Matrix
the reason Trump is in office the reason
everyone's now based in telling the
truth the reason the masculine youth are
rejecting the programming the reason all
of these things are happening was by no
small part down to my brother and I
personally it's not just us but we were
part of the entire culture War now what
I want to pay attention is the next
following Clips I'm very close to the
Trump family I know the well and I spoke
to Baron after the incident and I look
forward to once I am free being with
Donald Trump in person and reminding him
that he's a bulletproof B so why is he
all of a sudden close to the Trump
Administration Trump has said that he
knows nothing about it really can it be
that they framed him they said to him
this is what we can get you done for
however we're not going to do that we're
not going to do that do you really
believe Israel and mad is not behind all
of this do you guys really believe that
it's a Theory brothers and sisters he is
close to the Trump family he's been
acted very shady and weirdly lately
after his arrest they probably said to
him listen if you don't do this and
comply with what we're telling you
that's what's going to happen now all of
a sudden his Chang is truee he's
pleasing pleasing to the far right he is
saying things that are against Islam his
loyalty just seems to me to more to his
brother than anyone else it's like he
worships his brother I'll be honest with
you it's like even though he knows his
brother's a Christian we're not asking
him like to hate his brother nobody's
asking him but we believe true Iman is
that you love Allah and his messenger
more than
anybody anyone like Jesus said in the
Bible I've come to turn the father
against the mother and the mother
against the father and the children Etc
that you should love Jesus the Same Con
in Christianity so why is it that after
he's been released he is going to
America and he is close with the Trump
family why we know who the Trump family
is close with is real clearcut the guy
is moving for him look how he treated
zinsky and look how his treatment of um
that Satan Netanyahu you can see that
they are orchestrating something and
Andrew Tate when he shows his loyalty
more to a certain agenda there's a big
question mark on him that's a big
question mark on his faith I'll be
honest with you so let's read the
article in the BBC who are the T
brothers and Andrew T Andrew T 3 and his
brother trist 36 are Jewel us UK
citizens who claim to have made Millions
from the social media Empire their
online output was controversial even
before their legal troubles with a pair
attracting frequent criticism over
offensive statements about women the
pair have have an American father who
worked for the US Air Force in Britain
I'll be honest with you I'm not trying
to say would put everyone in that thing
but his father used to work for the CIA
he used to work for the US forces their
parents were met both in the UK before
moving to us after the parents' divorce
their mother moved to Luton England the
brothers spent time in the UK where they
built their early careers police in the
UK have linked Andrew Tate to quite
terrifying radicalization of boys and
young men in 2024 reporting violence
against women and girls which obviously
we know it's not true I mean there might
be some stuff that might be
controversial the brothers were arrested
in Romania 2022 they are facing separate
unrelated charges of rape and human
trafficking in the UK both brothers are
denying the charges against them in the
UK now why are the tape Brothers
traveling the US the brothers had been
under a travel ban in Romania for more
than 2 years while they were under
investigation speculation that they
would leave Romania had been mounting
ahead of their Journey after the pair
went quiet on social media they left
from Bucharest airport at around free
local time GMT on a private jet Bound
for Florida Source have told the BBC
prosecutors said that the travel ban had
been lifted and the pairs US passports
had been returned to them but
investigations into the alleged crimes
have not been dropped and they are
expected to return to Romania so who is
calling the shorts to allow them that
even though they're saying that the the
investigation is still Contin and it
hasn't been dropped for them to leave
Romania the Tates have a large US
following and are popular figures among
some elements of American right why
early in February some of Andrew T's
alleged victims said they were extremely
concerned by reports that us officials
had asked for his travel rest
restrictions to be relaxed why we need
to ask his questions why the Trump
Administration is sleeping in bed with
Israel and now they are working very
closely with Andrew Tate even though
Trump is saying he has no idea but it is
clear he does it came off the US Special
Envoy Richard greno raised the tapate
brothers with Romania's foreign minister
Emil harun at the Munich security
conference hunia said he had not
considered Green's approach as a form of
pressure greno told the financial times
his support for the brothers was evident
the Tates have the Tates have been vocal
supporters of US president Donald Trump
while close advisor Ellen musk Elon Musk
restored Andrew T's account on X after
he bought the social media platform and
now even Elon Musk is giving his
platform back to him who's Ed mus close
to who has he changed the T when he went
to Israel he done a U-turn I think this
is clearly poting a direction that I
have made videos saying that um we
cannot trust Tate I'll be honest with
you it is looking more and more evident
the less he talks about Palestinians uh
the genocide that's going on the more he
is closer to the trumps the more he is
close to El musk brothers and sisters
the matter is clearcut to me it is clear
where Andrew Tates uh loyalties lie and
what have the Tates and the Trump
Administration said about the journey
Andrew and Tristan Tate have not yet
commented on their trip to the US and
neither has the Trump
Administration brothers and sisters what
I'm going to say is anyone that puts an
individual a party a movement before his
faith Islam is not to be trusted and to
me we can see that more evidently more
openly we have to put Allah his
messenger true faith is felt when you
put Allah and his messenger before
anybody for that matter because your
true Brothers like Noam was told when
Allah told him when Alam said oh Allah
you said you was going to save my family
Allah rebuked Alam and said your true
family who those who have IM and we've
seen that in the B of families fighting
each other cuz true Iman is Believers
not my brother not this my true Brothers
my true family are those who are Muslim
those who are not Muslim are not my
family that's his out that's what Islam
teaches us and that's what we need to
abide by that's all I wanted to say
brothers sisters I don't know what you
make out of in let me know your comments
but we cannot trust this man